غالبية العائلات من السوريين ،
هذه عائلات اضطرت بالفعل
إلى الفرار من الحرب وفقدت الآن
منازلها في تركيا التي مروا بها بالفعل
كثيرًا ويمكنك أن ترى
ورائي الخيام التي تم نصبها
رسالة مفادها أننا '  لقد سمعنا من
الكثير من الناس هنا أن هذه
الخيام ليست كافية ، حيث أن العديد من
العائلات التي تحدثنا عنها
كانت تنام في الشارع خلال
الأسبوعين الماضيين منذ
وقوع الزلزال وكان هناك  الهزات
الارتدادية المدمرة خلال
الأسبوعين الماضيين والتي أثارت الخوف حقًا في
الكثير من هذه العائلات هنا ويمكنك
رؤية الأطفال ورائي ، أعني أن هذا
المخيم مليء بالأطفال الصغار الذين
ينامون في الشارع في البرد ليلاً
ويمكنك أن ترى  هم الآن يجمعون
بعض الوجبات الخفيفة والطعام الذي
قدمته مجموعات الإغاثة هنا
تركيا كارثة
وتشرف وكالة إدارة الطوارئ على
توزيع المساعدات هنا وكما
ذكرت هناك ، يعيش الآن حوالي 900000 شخص
في جميع أنحاء جنوب شرق تركيا
في خيام  مثل هذا حيث إنه مزدحم 10 City
هنا ولكن انظروا أنه لا يزال هناك
الكثير من الحاجة هنا والشعور هنا هو
أنه لم يتم عمل ما يكفي في هذه
المرحلة فقط هذا الصباح نشهد بالفعل
150 خيمة جديدة يتم بناؤها في هذه
المنطقة بالذات  هذا المخيم بالذات ولكن
بالنسبة لهذه العائلات التي تعيش في
الشارع خلال الأسبوعين الماضيين ، فقد
فات الأوان بالنسبة لهم